bonsoir à vous remercier d'être en
direct avec nous sur les france alors
160 milles 1 au moins 160 mille
personnes qui ont manifesté dans toute
la france selon le ministère de
l'intérieur ce sont des chiffres en
hausse par rapport à la semaine dernière
est-ce qu'on assiste à une mobilisation
qui va s'amplifier selon vous un
stéphane rozès vous l'avez dit quarante
mille manifestants de plus que la
semaine dernière le véritable
rendez-vous sera sans doute à la rentrée
je pense que c'est un mouvement qui peut
être ne s'étendra pas énormément mais
qui peut durer parce qu'il nous faut au
fond je ne sais pas ce qu'en pense le
sociologue michel fize ilum agglomère
des oppositions de nature différente
je dirai après les gilets jaunes et
notamment fin des gilets jaunes ou d'une
partie de personnes maintenant très
mobilisés contre le système politique
des inquiets sur la question du bassin
et ses effets des opposants pour des
raisons de liberté ou pas senneterre
possiblement une extension du mouvement
au plan syndical et social parce que va
y avoir pour les salariés d'entreprises
sont des obligations
hélas le front syndical divisé entre les
syndicats favorables aux pass senneterre
notamment la cfdt et des autres opposée
comme la cgt et la cftc dos voilà voilà
quelque chose de neuf
voilà quelque chose qui cristallise des
oppositions de nature diverse en plein
été effectivement on comprend que le
gouvernement avait estimé ces dynamiques
voir abp
un peu provocateur de centres où on
pouvait se demander s'il y avait une
instrumentalisation politique mais c'est
un monstre
alors il ya plusieurs choses dans ce que
vous dites stéphane rozès d'abord michel
fize est ce qu'à votre avis ce mouvement
il n'est pas amenée à s'amplifier comme
le sont le pense et stéphane rozès et
puis d'autre part l'aspect syndicale la
question de la convergence entre d'une
part les syndicats et les gilet jaune
qui revient sur la table à nouveau et
les divisions peut être que l'on verra
au niveau syndical sur la question de
l'extension du passé ni terre alors
chacun aura remarqué que nous posons les
mêmes questions depuis trois ans je
pense que aujourd'hui il y a une
confirmation d'un mécontentement qui
devient un contentement général parce
que multi catégorielles
multigénérationnel donc les foyers de
contestation sont plus nombreux
probablement pis plus virulents et je
pense qu'il n'y aura pas de pause
estivale
je partage tout à fait le sentiment de
stéphane rozès que la rentrée va
probablement être un grand moment
d'abord parce que la rentrée ne va très
certainement pas signifier la fin de la
crise sanitaire
j'entendais tout à l'heure sur un autre
plateau un spécialiste dire que la
charge virale du variant delta était
mille fois supérieur ils entendaient
bien mille fois supérieur à la charge
virale des variantes nous avons connu
jusqu'à présent et on annonce que les
variants qui vont suivre le variant
delta puisqu'apparemment il y en aura
d'autres pourraient être également plus
plus virulent encore
donc on va être tout toujours dans cette
atmosphère évidemment sanitaires très
très préoccupante
ce qui fait que le bout du tunnel va
probablement
durée encore durer encore un certain
temps alors il est évident je les dis
ici à plusieurs reprises la crise
sanitaire cache à peine toutes les
autres crises qui sont des crises
virulente structurelles crise sociale
crise encore une fois de la précarité
crise du chômage mais crise de la
pauvreté
bon tout ça a explosé au fil au fil des
années donc on est environné de crise et
j'allais oublier la crise
constitutionnelle
la crise des institutions bon
j'entendais tout à l'heure une bêtise
encore comparant évidemment la situation
politique française avec la situation de
la corée du nord
bien évidemment que ce monsieur devrait
pas pu dire ce qu'il a dit s'il avait
été en corée du nord donc il faut
s'interroger sur le fond c'est la
constitution même de la vème république
tu en penses aperçoit mieux aujourd'hui
qu'elle est comme gelée qualifier une
dictature constitutionnelle
voilà monsieur macro n'a pas besoin de
créer un coup d'état il n'a pas besoin
de faire un coup d'état
la constitution lui donne les pleins
pouvoirs et le pouvoir personnel
inauguré par un pharmacien de gaulle a
été a été a été encore une fois
poursuivi par ses successeurs donc
michel fize le mouvement que l'on
observe là depuis deux semaines
maintenant il est appelé à s'amplifier
les prochaines semaines si vous pensez
comme stéphane rozès que ce sera plutôt
à la rentrée maintenant savez il ya
toujours depuis 2010 8,1 d'élément
fédérateur fort ça a été le social
écologie politique insurrectionnel avec
les gilets jaunes puis ça a été
l'élément syndicale avec la contestation
des cheminots contre la réforme des
retraites
aujourd'hui c'est là l'élément sanitaire
est effectivement comme le disait
stéphane rose et tout à l'heure il y a
je dirais une une un enracinement de
catégorie voire d'individus parce que je
pense que ceux qui s'agrège à cette
contestation sanitaires ce sont ce sont
des individus
voilà qui pour une raison ou pour une
autre sont complètement insatisfaits de
la france
on peut parler véritablement de
convergence oui je suis d'accord avec ce
que dit michel fissure ni différents
éléments de convergence en même temps je
voudrais faire un petit contrepoint de
deux natures la première j'aurais dû lui
dire comme ancien sondeurs
quantitativement
pour l'heure les français sont
majoritaires autour de l'idée du passani
terre parce que il comprit skalli michel
fize il n'y a une inquiétude réelle des
français
au vu du variant d'un tas et des
français se disent au fond il y a deux
arbres la vaccination ou bien le fait de
rester chez et la psychologie le pays du
confinement le pays de recherche les
effets connus n'efface donc nous avons
une opinion inquiète
il se dit face à la pandémie ya seule
arme blanche raisonnable et le rex mais
sur les sondages à chaque guichet
d'accès aux passes
l'arrivée à la question des libertés qui
est d'une autre nature sur les sondages
et la raison stéphane rozès
certains sondages en fait montre que les
français sont en majorité favorables aux
décisions de l'exécutif il approuve la
décision
du président et mâcon de rendre
obligatoire la vaccination pour les
personnels soignants d'autres
professions avec des sanctions à la clé
c'est un sondage est là pour nos
confrères de bfm tv siens d'une tête et
du 3 juillet alors je sais pas ce que
vous avez entendu michel fize je vous
entends des plus ici n'ont demandé de
réagir justement la question des
sondages qui montrent que les français
sont majoritairement favorables aux
décisions de l'exécutif concernant la
vaccination pour les personnels
soignants obligatoire pour les
personnels soignants bon chacun sait
bien qu'il faut prendre les sondages
avec beaucoup de prudence mais il faut
savoir écouter aussi les personnes qui
sont interviewés dans la rue
régulièrement je pense qu'on ne peut pas
contester le fait qu'une majorité de
français aujourd'hui est acquise à
l'idée que le vaccin est probablement la
moins mauvaise des armes que l'on est à
disposition et est probablement que une
majorité de cette majorité est
aujourd'hui acquise à l'idée qu'il faut
en passer par là voilà parce qu'encore
une fois j'entends peau parlait beaucoup
de liberté mais il ya aussi bon ce sujet
de philosophie que l'on connaît bien
et d'abord les bacheliers sécurité
liberté à la liberté tel qu'on s'y avec
la sécurité et vice versa encore une
fois l'objectif dans cette affaire c'est
quand même d'arriver à la sécurité
sanitaire
ce qui veut dire à la bonne santé une
fois que nous serons débarrassés
débarrasser du virus
c'est ça l'objectif alors maintenant
pour le reste par les deux mesures
liberticides comme j'ai entendu ça me
paraît un petit peu excessif aussi par
mesure liberticide bien sûr on entend
une mesure qui détruit une liberté ont
malheureusement toute société aménageant
permanence les libertés qu'elle
reconnaît à ses membres
tout simplement pour que tous puissent
vivre correctement ensemble
moi je peux vous dire qu'effectivement
comme beaucoup de français quand je suis
sur une autoroute a fortiori des herbes
j'aimerais rouler plutôt à 150 à l'heure
qu'à 130
voilà bon et bien on accepte cette
réduction de liberté de même que le port
de la ceinture de sécurité ont les plus
les plus jeunes ne se souvient pas de
cette époque moi je me souviens bien
on avait crié à l'attentât aux libertés
le port de la ceinture de sécurité c'est
quelque chose qui était considéré comme
une atteinte au droit d'être dans sa
voiture michel 130 km/h photo c'est déjà
pas mal ans la limite à stéphane rozès
or justement ce rôle elle aspects
liberticides du projet de loi
d'extension du pass sanitaires comment
est ce que on doit comprendre ce point
de vue des contestataires aujourd'hui
donc mais michel field a dit les choses
si on s'y à la politique dans une
société humaine
c'est pour trouver les bons compromis
entre liberté individuelle liberté
collective sécurité sanitaire est le
propre du politique
michel fils il l'a dit dans une
tradition française très verticale c'est
pouvoir trancher par le haut le deuxième
sujet c'est l'attention des citoyens à
l'égard des gouvernements
et c'est vrai que alors on aurait pu
penser que le président matheron
résoudre elle est française
il semblerait que maintenant la
situation soit pire de ce boom plus
large en termes de défiance à l'égard
des institutions des politiques et même
sentiment que beaucoup de français coton
ou les divise
je suis frappé de la division à verse
chaque année politique et même le chat
c'est très frappant sans doute parce
qu'il s'agit là de la mort des
conceptions de la bonne démocratie en
guinée
celle frappant de bois des chambres
proche est question divise et or ont
parlé mais n'a dans une boutique qui le
révèle
et encore une fois il me semble que le
fonds tchèque n'est pas ton daksi nation
ou pas
le sentiment qu avec bath sanitaires on
organise un boulot ou n'hésiterai de
mauvais français parce que le politique
soit l'apanage ni chez comité suffisante
soit n'a pas immédiatement de vaccins et
derrière une base sanitaires et à
l'attention des données des données de
santé
c'est une question démocratique lourds
qui ne se fait pas impunément et là il
ya évidemment on passe à un niveau
supérieur sur la question de qui détient
les données de santé pourquoi très
rapidement pour conclure michel fize
l'événement de cet après midi c'est le
retour des contestataires contre
l'extension vue du passage du ter sur
les champs elysées et on est à quelques
encablures maintenant à deux dents d'une
échéance électorale importante la
présidentielle oui alors j'aimerais
rajouter mais je pense que le
politologue stéphane rozès fera
probablement la même analyse
je pense que sur le plan institutionnel
le pire est à venir pourquoi parce que
quel que soit le vainqueur de l'élection
présidentielle de 2022
qu'il s'agisse de monsieur macron s'y
est à nouveau candidat ou de marine le
pen ou de n'importe quel autre candidat
de la droite ou de la gauche
le gagnant n'aura pas de majorité au
parlement
c'est techniquement impossible c'est
techniquement impossible pour madame le
pen c'est techniquement impossible pour
monsieur lacrouts dont la majorité des
députés où ne se représenteront pas ou
ne seront pas réélus
voilà donc il est temps de considérer
qu'il y à une autre crise je dirais
sanitaires importantes que la crise
politique
anna est que la crise politique eh ben
elle s'appelle décentralisation
authentique
il est probable que si on avait dit lui
est un peu les responsabilités en
donnant les moyens évidemment chaque
échelon on n'en serait peut-être pas
cette situation de blocage
ah parceque vendée dans la situation où
un seul décide pour tous merci en quoi
ça
au souk ch alexandre dumas merci à vous
michel fize sociologue débat chez les
auteurs du livre de la bible mais
l'espoir aux éditions amis me disent
merci également à vous à stéphane rozès
politologue et président de cap conseils
analyses et perspectives